Thì hôm tượng Australia, ông Anthony Abani, SMA, Mẹ Bại, Thamu Một Tên Bố,
Cameras sẽ không đồng chủ trì hội nghị khí hậu có bà mềm mốt với thuộc gì kì trong bối cảnh với tắt kéo ra,
hãy dương hành lốc về quyền đăng ca sự kẹp của liên Quốc.
Anh caro chức lỏ để sớt giận giác hội nghị của Australia, nhưng hay bình đều trưa giúp phổ sơ đăng cai,
lột từ năm 2019, khiến tên trình lợi trọng chủ nhà bị điểm trẻ và đăng được thảo gỡ tại cố bà mưa đi đăng diện ra tại Brazil.
Pháp biểu tại Melbourne, ông Abani sẵn định quy định của con quốc quốc của liên Quốc về video khi hậu không cho phép một hình đồng chủ trì.
Mà thân ông cũng đã gửi thư cho tỏng thống thuộc gì kì chếp, Edu Wan, giám tìm cách thảo gỡ gỡ gỡ mắt.
Thì mà đỏ Australia đang bất đốc để đăng cao nhìn cụng cáng quốc đảo thái bình dường lạng diền.
Cộng đồng cáng quốc đảo thái bình dường của mấy tạm nước cụ ông hộ đứa sất này,
bởi họ đang phải đử mắt vì cụ nghiêm trọng từ nước bình dân của hậu bởi vì ý ía của hộ nghi cốp.
Cốp là dính đàn khi hậu của con chạm rất thế giới,
nơi cán lớn thường luận để đả thật và câu trong video khi hậu.
Đông thời đả phát triển thạch sự kẹp quy mô lớn,
giúp nước chủ nhà quảng mà hình đàn đất và cơ hội phát triển tế,
cua ra đường đăng cao của sẽ chủ trì cho chính nghĩa sức và con câu hội ngoại rao lớn.